tercera parada en la gira
latinoamericana de la presidenta de la
comisión europea Úrsula bounderley en
que tras visitar Brasil y después
Argentina este miércoles viajó a Chile
donde se reunió en el Palacio de la
moneda con el presidente chileno Gabriel
borics para firmar una serie de acuerdos
sobre todo vinculados al desarrollo del
hidrógeno verde una energía renovable
que será clave en tránsito hacia unas
energías limpias para la lucha contra el
cambio climático en el futuro el
presidente Gabriel boric en una
conferencia de prensa conjunta valoró el
hecho de que Chile ya es líder en
América Latina en la producción de
energías renovables y reconoció y valoró
el liderazgo que reconoce esta forma
Europa al invertir un total de casi 225
millones de euros aproximadamente 243
millones de dólares en que este
hidrógeno sea más competitivo en el país
por su parte Úrsula bounderlayer valoró
El contar con socios que tienen
pensamientos similares que también son
confiables recordó el mal momento que se
vivió en Europa tras el corte de gas por
parte de Rusia en el contexto de la
crisis de la Guerra de Ucrania y también
valoro positivamente el apoyo que ha
mostrado de forma un inequívoca chile al
estar del lado del pueblo ucraniano la
próxima parada y la última ya en esta
gira latinoamericana de la presidenta de
la comisión europea será el jueves a
México